I mean, do you really believe you could beat me in a straight-up old-fashioned fistfight?
let me tell you something...
me and you...
One on one. No one else around.
I will beat your ass like a Cherokee drum.
Maybe one day we'll find out.
Oh you better hope that day never comes.
*Sirens*
Stop him!
Don't let him get away!
The FATE of the
FURIOUS
They're still on us
These guys are taking it personal
You were only supposed to create a diversion Roman
That was complete destruction
What you want from me
I'm Roman Pearce man,
it's what I do.
Phase 2
Phase 2?
What's phase 2?!
Bombs away.
Hoolly shit!
You know what I like about you Dom?
You're genuine outlaw,
but your Family....
The hell of a job, brother.
When we get back to the base, beers on me.
...is about to go up against the only thing they can't handle...
...You
Did you ever think you'd betray your family
the way you did today?
Dominic Toretto
Just turned on us.
Well,  well, well 'd you look at that.
I don't know why he's doing this,
but that wasn't Dom.
She's the very definition of High-Tech terrorism,
and now she's working with your guy.
I think I've found my team
This should be interesting...
You want to play like that?
Ouch...
This is impossible.
Which is why they gonna need a little help.
I Will beat you like a Cherokee drum
It took longer than I expected
NEXT SPRING
If you're gonna catch Dom,
you guys are gonna work together
Surprise...
This is funny love
I've been waiting for this... we got a tank.
Let's roll
FAMILY
Here they come...
WILL BE BROKEN
I don't know if the old Dom is in there.
I don't give a damn.
I'm taking you down Toretto
Let's play!
Why they're shooting at me?!
I don't know man,
maybe because you're in an orange Lamborghini
SHUT UP TEJ!
Speakerbox blast go rat-tat-tat-tat!
In fact we about to go up like...
Oh shit!
See we're gonna need a bigger truck
The FATE of the FURIOUS
You're gonna turn your back on family?
#F8